so here mesh Johari and there's a very
appropriate work for this bookshop it's
great to have you here permission yeah
thank you yeah it's great to be here
it's it's been a lot of fun to see all
the different things presented
throughout the program and and thank you
to David and Dorothy for the invitation
to be able to present this this is
actually the first time I'm talking
about this work it's a joint work with
Gabriel Weintraub of is a professor in
the Stanford GSB and then really like
all the heavy lifting here and and you
know shaping the the problem and the
contributions bara Light PhD student at
the GSB deserves credit for that any
mistakes are definitely my own so yeah
and so it's first time presenting it so
still work-in-progress feedback is very
welcome we'd love to sort of understand
connections that we may have missed all
that type of stuff okay and also as a
result that narrative may still be
something that we will need to tweak so
feedback on that as useful as well I
guess first let me just tell you this is
like the you know background and how we
even got interested in this problem and
what we were interested in was the
observation that many platforms will
shape the information available about
one or both sides of the marketplace to
the other side of the market there has
been a you know I think a decent amount
of work of this sort this general flavor
in the community working on market
design matching markets things like that
in particular we were kind of focused on
filtering of sellers based on estimates
of their quality so some qualitative
examples would be you know platforms
that boost visibility of sellers that
have higher quality characteristics so
might be something like prime is
effectively a form of a badge that's
signaling higher quality in terms of
shipment guarantees on something like
Amazon Marketplace you know so at one
extreme you can have these features that
are actively boosting perceived higher
quality sellers in the platform
alternatively you could imagine features
that actually remove low quality sellers
from the platform kind of achieving I
mean these are basically just two sides
of the same coin and and I'd say this is
most common on a wide range of service
but I call service market places like
ride-sharing delivery home cleaning
things like that so broadly speaking I'm
gonna refer to that phenomenon as I did
in the title as quality selection by the
platform in particular and I'm gonna
just know that from this point forward
there's gonna be sort of a stylized
connection back to the kind of formal
the the more like kind of practical
operational setting of platforms like
this I do think an interesting question
around this work is you know bridging
that gap one step forward this will be
very much a theory talk but at least
like if you if you're willing to grant
this kind of qualitative motivation for
what we're doing then the type of
question we're asking is about a
particular sort of strategy that's often
seen which is where what you know what
they're effectively doing here it's not
just filtering sellers kind of
arbitrarily but really of low quality so
what we ask is when is it optimal to
keep only high quality sellers in the
platform and then remove the rest okay
so in order to get you through the talk
I'm going to have to add a lot of
scaffolding around trying to answer a
question like this and that's really
what my slides are trying to trying to
convey so here's an outline of what I'll
do the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to set up - as I mentioned
stylized models of markets two-sided
markets which have the feature that the
platform is going to be making quality
selection decisions inside of them and
it's in the talk it's goal will be to
maximize total transaction value that is
admittedly sort of a artificial
objective function it's kind of
motivated by the fact that in many of
these platforms the the way the platform
monetizes is by taking say a percentage
of transaction value so you can take
what we're doing here and add on to it
of you know a fee structure where it's
setting feast of one or both sides of
the marketplace and kind of worked on
that for the purposes of the talk I've
removed fees entirely and just made this
the objective to keep it simple in the
to market models there's one commonality
and then one distinction the commonality
is that both of these market models will
share a a common way of describing
information that the platform is
providing to buyers about seller quality
okay so I'll describe that
in one place the models differ in what
the what the platform is doing in the
first model actually these are in the
wrong order in the first model I show
you I'll show you one more seller's
strategy involves choosing the quantity
that they're going to provide and in the
other model I'll show you where I'll
show you a model where the seller
strategy involves choosing prices and as
you can imagine the platform
intermediation here then has to involve
kind of the other dimension of the
transaction so in this the platform will
be setting prices here the platform will
will there will be kind of a an aspect
of the allocation rule that's going to
be certain mechanically determined so
I'll show that to you okay so these
these models were interesting to us
because they were kind of capturing
different flavors of what what the
combination of intermediated and
transactions in these markets could look
like what was really interesting from
our perspective is that ultimately we
realized that when we think about what
information disclosure in these settings
was doing we were able to translate that
into a price discrimination problem
really like a menu construction problem
so I suppose if there's like one
takeaway from our work at least at the
current stage of evolution the main
takeaway is that we have these kind of
two exemplars of stylize market models
that ultimately both feed into
transforming information design in this
context into a price discrimination
problem and so the I'll show you kind of
at least I'll provide some description
of how that's happening and then that
price discrimination problem I think is
kind of theoretically interesting in and
of itself and so we will solve that and
I solve I mean I'll show you
structurally kind of what we learn from
it and use the resulting solution to try
to characterize quaddle equality
selection here so that's the outline
when that explains the title so the
point is that the talk is about quality
selection but our approach to
understanding this quality selection
problem is through a price
discrimination problem okay all right so
let's so basically on that roadmap the
first step will be for me to describe to
you seller quality and what it means for
the platform to provide information
about seller quality like I said that's
going to be a common construct between
these two models and then the next step
will be to describe the two different
market models and then finally talk
about this price discrimination problem
that we use to understand
the quality selection problem okay by
the way David I didn't track exactly
when we started this is like okay great
I'll adjust to whatever you tell me so
okay cool
okay so first of all let's start just
with quality before we talk about the
platform to keep things simple I'm just
going to think about a continuum of
sellers on 0 1 where X indexes their
quality you know in general you could
have them you could have a more kind of
general type set for quality here you
could have a different distribution than
uniform none of that's particularly that
important for what I'm gonna talk about
so just keep that simple for the talk ok
alright so that's seller quality
basically the sellers type directly
identifies their quality the quality is
of course only going to you know I've
quality's a loaded term at this point
I've haven't told you anything about
buyer utility the quality will become
quality the type will become quality
when I show you buyers pay off so
that'll happen a little later ok so now
I have to tell you a little bit about
what the platform knows about seller
quality and certainly like a richer
version that captured operational
details we'll talk about how a platform
acquires information about seller
quality I'm not doing that here in this
talk I'm just going to assume that
there's some finite partition of the
type space that captures the information
available to the sellers there's a very
standard kind of form of informational
model where the what we say is that
these you know what the platform knows
about any particular seller is which of
these subsets they live in so a eyes are
always going to index ground truth from
the perspective of the platform and the
platform's decision essentially when it
comes to information sharing with the
buyers amounts to how much do I want to
share with you about these a eyes now I
can't share anything finer than the a
ice that's what I know and really then
it comes down like how coarse do I want
to make what I share with you ok so p0
indexes that kind of ground truth
platform information and as I said you
know what the platform knows is only
that the seller lives in that
corresponding said questions on this
yeah
not so it won't be because the sellers
type will play a role in things like
participation or quantity selection and
so therefore different sellers of
different types within these sets may
choose let's say different amounts they
produce for example that in turn will
affect buyers beliefs if they choose a
particular set of sellers okay yeah yeah
yeah and you'll see this clearly later
one of the weirdnesses in the talk is
I'm trying to show you this information
structure before I've defined buyer and
seller payoff so that's because there's
two different models that rely on the
same structure so just grant me a little
bit of license there but yeah basically
in the end this will matter because
there will be heterogeneous behavior
depending on type okay so as I said the
platform can choose what sellers to
include in the platform and what to show
about them to prospective buyers now
choosing who to include in the platform
basically means do I include an AI or
not in the platform right I could if I
cut one of these out it just means those
sellers are just not available so that's
like removal of those sellers okay now
formally an information structure
therefore you know translating this into
plain English amounts to taking unions
of these AIS and not necessarily needing
the entire interval so you can you can
keep whatever you want out of these
first of all and then take unions of
them as you choose okay that's
essentially what's said here it's a
family of disjoint sets that are where
every single set is a union of elements
of that kind of ground truth partition
one one definition that'll be important
is that this this P okay this
information structure is is the
abbreviation I'll use just to save words
on the slides so an information
structure is called one separating if it
consists of only a single element okay
and in this case basically what happens
is that that means you've taken a union
of some subset of these kept that and
everything else has gone you've removed
all the other sellers we're particularly
going to be interested in when you know
information structures of that sort are
optimal and moving one step beyond that
if
you probably picked up on the fact that
I kind of need I want a little bit more
than that
I really want one separating information
structures that what I've kept is at the
top and what I removed is at the bottom
that's sort of what we're looking for
and I'll show you to market models where
that's what you know now I can be a
little more precise about this overall
question I'm trying to answer what are
conditions on the markets I'm going to
define under which the right thing for
the platform to do is that kind of one
separating information structure yeah
first element and that's a zero
no so it's if the information structure
consists of only a single element that's
a good question let me actually go
through this and it'll be clear so let's
first just go back to that example with
like the for AI so that's the ground
truth partition right so one information
structure might be something where I
remove all of these sellers that's the
black I keep these two subsets and in
these two subsets I actually let you the
buyer know for any particular I show you
that there are two different sets of
sellers another thing I could do is
remove these two but then take the union
of these in which case has a buyer I'm
not telling you that these are different
sets of sellers I'm just telling you
there's a set of sellers out there and
you all you know about that set of
sellers is that they're between 0.5 and
1 of course you need to know a bit more
than that in the game to form accurate
beliefs in all of that consistent
beliefs but we'll talk about that in a
second yeah so to answer your question
this is one separating and in particular
it includes two subsets of the original
ground truth partition but those have
been I've taken a union of that so that
the information structure that the
platform has chosen consists of only one
set
right okay so you know kind of as
Hassan's question hinted you know it's
like a really incomplete description of
a game obviously because all I'm telling
you is about information structure and
nothing about what buyers are sellers or
the platform are doing so I need to fill
that in and that I'll fill in in in
these two different examples okay so now
let me actually maybe just pause for a
sec ask if there's any other questions
on this sort of model of information
structure you know obviously you could
get a lot richer than what we have here
but this felt like something where we
were hoping we would be able to make
some tractable progress that was really
yeah that's a dangerous exercise but
let's go down this road okay go ahead
certification that the platform creates
or background checks you either pass a
background check or you don't
yeah I think of it I think that's that's
probably a good way to think about I
think about is at the extreme says two
different types of information structure
in the real world one would be what you
just said which is where I'm effectively
partitioning sellers through a signal
badge something like that so that's
where I thought of like like prime
really is conveying quality directly
because you know as a customer there is
some service guarantee that comes along
with prime Amazon Marketplace that's one
and then the other extreme is the one is
is sort of complete removal so that when
I see the platform it's not that you're
badging anything that's there it's just
that you've removed a bunch of stuff
that's not there anymore
now in between those extremes are things
that platforms do in for example
adjusting search results and things like
that I have struggled with that a little
bit we all have Gabriel bar and I in
thinking about you know it's it's not
really that obviously because there's an
endogenous a there that's not being
captured in the model and I think that's
kind of one of the interesting ways to
maybe push forward and think more about
what information structures mean when
you incorporate that as well because
that's obviously a big part of what real
world information structure design looks
like that maybe this isn't capturing
yeah
your information structure like I do it
sets like a to Union a three and a two
you can get working
oh that's a really good question no so
the the information structure I'm
creating is disjoint so it's like yeah
yeah
just to clarify if it's a eight - is not
in P that means that a two is a two
sellers are not in your market right
right they can't participate
I mean basically what happened is that
the platform remove them from the
matching technology completely there's
just no way for buyers to select them
anymore and this is not personalized so
it's everybody agrees on
oh you mean yeah like yeah yeah yeah and
that'll be clear - as I go through the -
mark maybe that's a good sign that I
should say more now about whatever
models are yeah right the the notion of
X will be like vertically differentiated
in a in a uniform way all right okay so
let's start with this one so I called
this model quantity setting sellers I
probably need a parenthesis here that
says an price setting platform okay
underneath it so let me show you what
that looks like okay so first step is
kind of what I've already told you the
platform sees this ground truth
partition and then chooses a information
structure in the way that we just
described so hopefully we're all kind of
good with that the hut format at the
same time also chooses what I'm going to
call price function which has the
feature that it's constant on subsets in
the chosen information structure and
really this is just the price is not
conveying additional information beyond
the information structure okay so what
this amounts to is that the platform is
telling buyers that if you select you
know one of these subsets in the
information structures to transact with
then the price you're going to get
charges whatever the price function is
telling you
okay so now I've got this price function
sellers are just going to take the price
function as a given they're going to
maximize profit to choose quantities and
I'll show you what their profit function
looks like so you understand why there's
why there's going to be sort of a
natural a straightforward mapping here
from their optimization problem to the
quantities they choose now given those
quantities buyers can form beliefs about
the average quality of sellers in these
different groups and they will use that
to determine whether to buy an if so
from which set of sellers to purchase
okay
the rationing in in a given set it is
kind of a simple and obvious thing which
is a sort of proportional rationing so
let me explain that a little more detail
so from a cellar standpoint so a type X
seller who chooses to produce a quantity
Q and faces this price now this okay let
me explain what P of B is bi is a subset
of the information structure it is a is
an element to the information structure
so it's a set in the information
structure okay this have been like 8/3
Union a for and what I showed you before
P FBI is that price that the platform
set for that group the seller sees that
price and they're thinking how much
should I produce that's the quantity
setting choice by the seller and we kind
of have a simple form here where there's
a polynomial cost function with a
coefficient that depends on your type so
in particular kind of a key thing that
that's important in this model is that
this cost is increasing as a function of
seller type so higher quality possible
to produce okay and then the profit is
what you'd expect quantity times price
minus cost and so this like when the
seller solves this optimization problem
holding the price fixed they're able to
spit out a quantity that they're willing
to produce so now a buyer who chooses to
buy from the set VI of sellers okay
knows sort of what is the expected
quality that I will see if I get
randomly matched into a seller these are
all infant tesam all right so as a buyer
I'm looking at this now measure of
quality induced by how much each type of
seller in a given B is choosing to
produce so that's back to your question
is on because of the structure of this
the amount that a type X seller produces
will be heterogeneous within a single
set and so that's this like this is a
I'm compressing a ton into this notation
where the buyer has formed a belief
about the average quality of sellers in
the set B I the buyer is of type M and
that's how much they value quality
relative to price okay
so buyers have this kind of
heterogeneous type m
there's a distribution over types that
isn't really important for what I'm
saying right now but we'll talk about
that when we get to the price
discrimination problem its distribution
over buyer types okay so fire of type M
is interested in maximizing this net
utility where the expectation is with
respect to this induced belief yeah so
the profit is based on the quantity that
you choose to produce as a yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that's one of the weird
things here is that this will only make
sense if the market actually clears and
that's one of the equilibrium conditions
so the equilibrium I think takes this
shape more of like a competitive
equilibrium in some sense that like one
of the conditions here is that with
price taking sellers the market has to
clear and you'll see that in the next
slide
yeah
yeah I mean essentially there's think of
this as kind of I'm either purchasing or
I'm not basically and then Who am I
purchasing from so the the who is the bi
obviously I can't pick within the bi
which X I want it expected x given bi
that's what's induced by the quality
distribution that's generated by the
sellers in that bucket yeah yeah it's
like that it's the combination of whose
in the bucket Oh
see Waits's yeah it's whose in the
bucket and
turn off the screensaver so there we go
yeah it's who's in the bucket and how
much did they choose to produce probably
the highest quality type in the bucket
make stuff then then yeah right yeah
and I have to be consistent with that
when I induce this believe that's the
endogenous a and actually since you said
that let's just write that here that's
exactly bullet one the buyers beliefs
are consistent with sellers actions
buyer and seller decisions are
respectively optimal with respect to
this utility was just defined and this
is what Nichols question was about that
supply has to equal demand for each of
these sets the markets have to clear in
each set okay so now yeah so the buyer
is for every seller okay does not have
to equal so that's captured by this
because I'm sort of aggregating up all
the demand so think of it this way when
a buyer chooses bi they don't get to
choose the X they buy from they only get
to choose the bi so from the platform's
perspective there's this mass of bi
demand coming in and on the other side
there's this mass of bi stuff being
produced the fact that some of the BI
stuff has different qualities within it
the buyers don't know so I could take
this and just randomly ration it out
over here and that clears the market as
long as the two quantities match okay
okay so so okay now we get to this key
observation that's kind of the
connection to price discrimination an
information structure and a price are
implementable if there exists such an
equilibrium okay so you can see a basic
problem here that was basic that was
inside Nikhil's question I could just
pick any information structure any price
I want but the market doesn't clear if
there's no equilibrium there then that's
not valid so in order for me to actually
you know pick an information structure
in a price that I could kind of use I
have to be clearing the market in some
way and that's this condition that
there's an equilibrium okay now here's
the key observation let's say that I
pick a P P pair that's implementable now
what's going on in equilibrium from a
buyer's perspective you've just shown me
a collection of these
of sellers and for each set you've shown
me a price and because of these expected
you know payoffs expected quality levels
that I compute from these beliefs I have
an expected quality for that set so
that's a menu so what this means is that
every time the platform is thinking
through which P P pair do I want to use
effectively what it's doing is
manipulating this menu on the buyers
side okay and so then what that does is
it says that we've got a really kind of
highly complicated menu design problem
here where the platform is picking a
menu where feasibility of a menu is
defined by which menus are implementable
in this sense does it make sense if that
makes sense the next model is kind of
similar with with price setting instead
at least as far as this key observation
is concerned there's a lot of redundancy
in the talk where I just say the same
thing over and over again in hopes that
you'll believe me by the end so this is
one of those things that I'll say again
okay yeah all right things really
different if the if the sellers get to
spend effort to produce
different quality I mean a lot of times
I would think that somehow some sellers
of little quality is that they decided
yeah yeah so you're thinking of a game
where the the type of the seller or
something it could be endogenous which
is determined by their own decision to
exert effort capability right yeah
that's a great question so I haven't
thought about that a priori something
tells me that one concern I would have
there is so I mean at that point I'd be
backing up your type as a seller to
something one level back I need a model
of both what the platform knows about
that as well as endogenous Lee what the
platform learns about the actual quality
level you've chosen to produce so I'd
want to rethink my information model a
little bit in that context and then yeah
I'm not I don't want to commit to what
the finding might be in that case so
it's interesting question oh that's a
really good comment okay let me quickly
run through this model so I can get to
the price discrimination results okay so
in this model essentially what happens
is you have the same first stage
platform sees ground truth chooses
information structure in this case
sellers are going to choose whether or
not they enter and they'll choose the
price they want to sell at if they do
enter buyers will again form beliefs
about sell their quality and choose
whether to buy and if so from whom
that's the same bullet as before the key
thing that's important here is that one
of the challenges we had is we did not
want prices to signal anything other
than which set you're in how do you get
there
so one of the things I love about
talking to avatar Doge about research is
that she loves referring to things like
this as a cheat and it is a bit of a
cheat the cheat here is to use Bertrand
competition which is fine because that's
like the classic model of price
competition in my view so the good
starting point but one advantage of
using Bertrand competition within each
set is that really achieves for us this
goal that we don't end up conveying
anything at extra through the price so
let me make that clear on the next slide
so a lot of this looks the same in the
sense that I've got sellers and buyers
making choices
what is the sellers profit function now
here they're not going to choose the
quantity this will be determined through
some allocation in equilibrium they do
choose a price and then here they just
have
constant marginal cost this cost is a
function of the ground truth set they
live in and we make the assumption that
all sellers in each in the same ground
troops set have the same cost and then
this cost is increasing in the index of
the set so this is the same thing that
higher quality costs more okay but if
you put this together with Bertrand
competition within a bi set then what
that's going to drew
it'll drive prices down in equilibrium
to the lowest marginal cost within a bi
in the informations so that's how that
helps us it keeps us from communicating
extra information out this is the same
as before a buyer who chooses to buy
from a particular bi this is the same
payoff function expectation is again
about induced quality and this is the
Bertrand competition piece of it the
price in a in a given B I we assume
mechanically is the lowest price there
and what this is saying is that buyers
are just getting matched to only sellers
who are selling at the lowest price in
that group so I think that is something
that we'd like to work on more to think
about sort of other forms of price
setting where we can you know still end
up with with kind of a well-defined Oh
at least attractable model to study okay
so equilibrium conditions only sellers
at the lowest price in each bi are
active that's per trend competition
quantity allocation follows the Bertrand
type of rule where we ration among the
sellers at the lowest price buyer
beliefs are consistent with sellers
entry decisions and buyer seller
decisions are optimal for each side same
as before and then finally same
observation when you think about what
goes on in equilibrium here I've shown
you a collection of these sets in
equilibrium buyers are facing a menu
where there's again price and there's an
expected quality attached to each set
and the platform is choosing an
information structure that's shaping
that menu so it's a very different menu
design problem now but at least in terms
of the concept of what the talk is doing
it's the same reduction
in Russia yeah the the quality induced
by this now is only the people in sent
bi that are active right right exactly
so in particular let's say bi included
multiple a ice yeah
the costs are increasing it's Bertrand
competition so the active folks will be
the lowest a I in in that in that be a
yeah
so here what the platform is really
doing is that the I guess the way to
think of it I think of it is that the
removal is kind of really the key action
in the platform here because the ones
who are not available at all
the cost is going to end up being kind
of the lowest among the remaining after
detective so did I follow correctly that
unlike in the quantity case that the
cost for production depends only on this
coarsened yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
went through these slides deliberately
quickly Dean so you wouldn't notice that
oh no that's absolutely right yeah so so
here the let me state that as kind of an
open question which is that the ideal
thing to be able to do would be to get
to a point where you actually or you
have a richer kind of price setting
model but nevertheless like complete
type information of the sellers not
being communicated through an
equilibrium otherwise that kind of
eviscerates the whole thing and so our
you know in in some sense you can think
of landing on this as a way to really
prevent additional information
transmission through the price which so
they're coming at it from a rational
expectations equilibrium point of view
like obviously that's something that you
know we studied a lot over the years
which is how much information do prices
contain here is sort of deliberate that
because we were focused more on the
platform's intervention how much
interview information is being conveyed
we really wanted to stay away from that
that lands us into this kind of
relatively simplistic price setting
model I think you know that's that's
kind of an important thing to think
about which is how far can we push past
that
what's interesting is that the platform
in the previous setting at most chose as
many prices as their word CIS yeah yeah
it has to choose continuum of quantities
yeah so the thing about the quantity
allocation is it's that like the
Bertrand rule is the thing that ends up
determining you know kind of how so
buyers are choosing how much to buy
that'll determine kind of incoming
demand that gets rationed among the
sellers who are at the lowest price
right this was a end up producing a well
amount yeah so the queue yeah the queue
that that that arises here this will be
determined by this will be determined by
what's the mass of sellers who chose to
sell at the lowest price relative to the
demand that was generated given kind of
the demand the the buyer optimization
yeah great questions anything else I
think I have like 10 to 15 minutes left
so I'll use that to talk about price
discrimination okay so now for something
completely different so so basically in
these two models stylized as they may be
we've reduced the problem into looking
like a price discrimination problem in
the way that I tried to convince you you
know through the through the last two
sections so now what we want to do is we
want to leverage that connection to
characterize information structure
design the two models by actually
thinking about a price discrimination
problem that somehow encapsulate so of
these for us what was really interesting
about this is that it that's like highly
non-trivial because if you just think
about what the menus are that are
available to the platform they depend in
some really complicated way on the
choice of information structure this is
true even in the return setting it's not
so simple to work through the menu
design problem because there are
constraints like you're not in the
Fortran setting you know you're
constrained us to the prices that are
available to you right so it's not you
have to think about sort of conditions
under which remember that our overall
goal was to say what are conditions
under which keeping the top removing the
bottom ends up being the optimal
strategy so how do we how do we get
there okay so the type Empire has
utility I'm Q minus P for a product of
quality cubed price P this is the same
that's what I wrote down before I accept
now we're in price discrimination
setting so this is kind of a standard
utility model for you for buyers in a
price discrimination setting ok now
earlier I didn't really tell you
anything about buyer types other than to
say a buyer of type M valued price to
quality in a certain way what we find is
that what we're going to do is
characterize our results in terms of the
shape of this distribution of buyer
types and the distribution of buyer
types essentially says you know what's
the mass of buyers with different values
it can be anything up to the open
positive real line and no atoms
okay so a few more terms an important
aspect of what we do is that we focus on
finite menus okay this is first of all
it's starting with a finite partition
anyway so that's partly coming from that
but it's also because it's just a lot
easier to think about the analysis in
this setting we allow kind of continuum
menus that would be very difficult to to
work through the analytics of what I'm
about to show you so a set of K distinct
PQ pairs is a K menu so a distinct is
important and then I'm just going to
sort of assume that anytime I show you a
menu I've ordered it an increasing price
order okay so the peas are always going
to be increasing that the parentheses
see here just indicates these are the PQ
pairs that are associated with that with
that menu a script C will denote the set
of feasible menus di of C is the demand
for a particular item on the menu when
that menu is offered and that's
determined by this F thing here
now what's the platform's goal to choose
a menu to maximize its profit which is
price times dimin
okay so um
there's only one real definition I need
to crack this price discrimination
problem open and that is this definition
of one rich which is actually fairly
simple so let me first say it in words
and then I'll translate back to the
notation so for any menu that I give you
that has this Associated profit right
what I want to do is you know in the end
what I'm looking for the kind of result
I'm looking for is that a one menu is
optimal in other words that a menu that
contains only one item that one item and
associated price is optimal that's what
we're going to look for in the price
discrimination problem that's what will
map back to one separating information
structures being optimal so what I need
is something that allows me to kind of
get over to optimizing over one menus
and really the the assumption that we
make the assumption we need or the
definition we need is that for any menu
you give me there's some one menu in the
set of feasible contracts feasible menus
it has the property that the profit at
that one menu let's say P Q is at least
as high as the profit at the highest PQ
pair on the menu you picked so C is some
menu with a bunch of things in it
there's one thing that has the highest
price in there what I need here is just
that I can find some one menu in my
feasible space of menus whose profit
exceeds the profit of that stay at that
item on its own or that you know that
item an Associated price on its own so
this will often just be sad if I could
just pick this if this was in my
feasible I'm done because obviously this
is trivial just make that PK QK
sometimes I may not be able to pick this
an example when I will not be able to is
that first quantity setting example when
I end up doing this reduction the
problem is that if I move from the B is
that I had to only keeping the top one I
change something about the quantities
that are available so that means I don't
actually get the same thing back so
that's why we needed to expand the
definition of elements and you know
three menus don't include the choices in
your two menus in your woman is they
don't necessarily they don't have to be
the say yeah exactly I mean of course
thinking about as a price discrimination
problem you could think of something
simple where like you know these are all
sort of
subsets of some like base set of
possible pairs right then this is
trivially satisfied it's it's not in
this induced thing yeah and that's where
that's how it gets interesting yeah okay
all right and actually how this comment
is just what you said David I mean it's
like if if that was already there this
is a trivial definition some of those
interesting things where there's it'd be
hard for me to conceive of giving a talk
only on price discrimination and then
tossing this up because it's like out of
the ether pulling a price discrimination
problem how would I motivate for you
that that wasn't present but it's really
this like it's the fact that the
information structure design problem is
inducing this weird menu constraint that
may not satisfy this alright so here's
the main result suppose that M F of M is
convex on its support and that the space
of feasible menus in this price
discrimination problem is one rich then
for any menu in that set there exists of
one menu with higher profit which this
is like a too long of a statement okay
basically the way I would look at it is
if M F of M is convex on one menu is
optimal and the only thing that's
stopping you there is you just need to
know that there exists an optimal one
menu simple assumption for that would be
say something like the set of 1 menus in
the set is compact so that you can
actually find an optimal solution
basically the main point is that if M F
of M is convex in its support then
there's just an optimal one
statements about ceiling that are
actually statements about F as well
right like demanded are a function of
the types which is the
distribution yeah right you're saying
like this right here right like the the
profit function depends on one Ridge
right right yeah so this actually yet
another condition yes that's right
that's right that's right but I guess
the that's in thinking about the
problems where we're applying this
reduction the thing is that whether this
is one rich or not is sort of determined
structurally by the nature of the of the
of the like a market model and within
that when we layer this on that's kind
of what we're using to be able to get to
optimality in our case of a1 separating
information structure that's what
that'll reduce to so let me see let me
skip the proof right now and I'll come
back to it with the last couple of
minutes if David indulges me and then
let me first just fill in a few remarks
in the theorem and the reductions and
then we can go back okay so first of all
I don't know if I should call this a
partial converse or a counter example
but basically if M F of M is not convex
you know then we can so we can find an
example so to Nicole's point maybe a
more precise way to say this is we can
find an example where M F of M is not
convex and the set of contracts is not
one rich the set of venues of the
available menus is not one rich where no
one menu is optimal okay that's one you
might for us to actually a really
interesting exercise which I'm not
totally sure we're done with yet just
because of how wide-ranging the
literature on on pricing and price
discrimination will be is just to
understand how this relates to other
price discrimination problems now the
closest relationship from our
perspective is to this work by Bergman
and co-authors on price discrimination
where the the set the menu that's being
presented as a finite set that's true
here to the big difference from that
work is that our costs are all 0 from
the platform's perspective in the in a
typical price discrimination problem
when you're including something there's
a cost associated to that for the
principal and all our costs effectively
are 0 in this price discrimination
problem are the results in techniques as
a result looked quite different from
what we've seen so far
since their marks on the theorem let me
give a little bit of intuition before
the proof yeah oh five minutes okay
great then you're not allowed to ask me
any more questions David yeah
thanks for the warning so so on
elasticity you know one way you can
translate the condition on em F of em is
that that's basically saying that the
elasticity of the density of types is
above a lower bound minus two so it's
kind of that leads to a natural
intuition for what's going on if you're
at a one menu you think about expanding
to a two menu okay what's going to
happen is that you're going to increase
the mass of buyers but some buyers now
take advantage of a lower price when you
do that and so the question is like you
know when is that trade-off worthwhile
well when the in elasticity is not too
low in particular this bound holds then
this kind of increase in the mass of
buyers is not that high so it's not
worthwhile okay and you can see this
like in these examples here so here's an
example where the density is has
elasticity one and a half there's like a
two menu a 1 min you have kind of
arbitrarily putting cut points and what
you see is that when I when I move you
know when I'm looking at like kind of
the via impact of moving from one
separating one menu to a two menu of
course it depends where the cut points
fall but what you see is that you know
because this is sort of not too sharp
you don't lose a lot in this region
that's roughly the intuition and this is
an example of elasticity is for
intuitively kind of what's happening is
that a move of to cut out the collection
of buyers you could have captured with
an additional item in your menu actually
loses a lot of volume that's the
intuition from the elasticity okay so
let me take like two minutes and walk
through the proof oh we actually saw
everyone do the reductions real quickly
right so the reductions now are actually
fairly straightforward given everything
I've said to you right so just to remind
you in the quantity setting model a
choice of information structure by the
platform induces a menu in the way that
we talked about quality basically
amounts to expected quality is seen by
the buyers price is set by the platform
that converts us to a price
discrimination problem what the theorem
implies is that if M F of M is convex
and you have an additional technical
condition and I'll explain that in a
second
then a1 separating information structure
is optimal and that's because of one
separating information structure in the
in the market design problem is
equivalent to a 1 menu in the price
discrimination problem now what's this
additional technical condition the
technical condition is something that
ensures that the top-quality sellers
will provide enough supply ok so a
problem might happen if the top-quality
sellers is actually just a very small
set of sellers and therefore you're
getting very little production out of
them remember you have to clear the
market somehow so back to Kenna this is
related to Nicole's point that this
technical condition here this is sort of
a structural condition on the model that
we define that is needed to ensure one
richness in there in the analogous price
discrimination problem and in this case
besides the fact that a1 separating
information structure is optimal it
takes the shape that you remove low
quality sellers as I brought up at the
beginning may be in the interest of time
I won't say is much here this is the
price that the price setting model
basically the same result here no
technical condition is needed for one
richness ok so now I think I have like
one or two minutes to briefly mention
the proof let me just quickly mention
that so the proof amounts to the
following which is that if you pick a
menu that just remind you the result is
this right I'm going to show you how do
we think about this if M F of M is
convex how do we show you that a1 menu
is optimal so the basic idea is that
first of all just assume without loss of
generality that the demand for every one
of these items in your menu is positive
you pick some C demand for every single
thing is positive if not you just remove
the things where demands not positive
and as a result of that you can assume
that the prices and the qualities are
both ordered together in the menu
okay once once you've done that you've
got pivotal types of customers who are
exactly indifferent between adjacent
items in the menu that's this kind of a
simple like you know exercise here shows
you that your profit for that takes on a
really clean form it's the sum of P I
minus P I minus one times the
distribution applied at these pivotal
types add it up this is kind of a nice
succinct expression for profit as a
result okay
so what's cool is that we now use
convexity to basically you conduct C
together with Jensen's inequality to
bound this that's what we get right here
oh sorry there's a question yeah let me
take it offline cuz I'm just about out
of time I can explain that in the break
you also see me a lot so we can talk
about that at Stanford too okay so yeah
so using Jensen's inequality and
convexity so a particular convexity of F
of M M implies that this is convex
jointly is a function of P and B we can
use that together with Jensen's
inequality to get this bound and that
bound as a result allows us to say that
the profit under a one seperating
contract which includes just the the of
one separating one menu sorry that
includes just the top P nqn is higher
than under your full seat and now we
apply one richness we know there's
something else in our set that does
better than PN QN and that's the proof
so really like the proof amounts to this
mix of convexity applied to these terms
with Jensen's inequality it's really
great
all right so I think that's it I'm about
out of time and so let me just wrap up
with this slide there's a couple of nice
findings here I think I'll let you read
these but the main thing I want to
emphasize is that for us what was really
interesting is this link between
information structure and price
discrimination I do think that if you
think of what the platform and this gets
back to your question Kiara I think of
the platform's is actively choosing what
information they want to show about
sellers and so what's nice is to be able
to transform that into something where
we're able to leverage you know kind of
a different technology that we've spent
a lot more time thinking about because
obviously information design in these
two-sided markets is a fairly
complicated thing okay stop there thank
you one is in our great wisdom we have
built a longer break into the schedule
so we're at you I'm great until 3:30 so
you kept talking all right before you
all find friends to talk with and share
ideas which we really encourage you to
do or go for a walk in the sunshine get
coffee etc Kiara is talking at 3:30 so
don't go very far away we really
encourage you to stick around and find
people to chat with also the eight of
you I think I see most of you in the
room who are speaking at 5:00 p.m. this
evening and the lightning round
please come and add your talk to the
laptop at the front of the room and
we'll make sure we're ready to go there
and also if you are uncomfortable having
your talk recorded in the lightning
round please come find me and let me
know okay so we're on break until 3:30
thanks